salut à tous c'est pêcheur de trésor
aujourd'hui Quentin est un transporteur
de
genever et surtout on est là pour pêcher
tu vas arrêter de jouer avec les mainant
tu vas mon bout de
ton en plus tu restes S c'est
bien
plus
se ah mais tu as chopé le gros truc oh
là c'est énorme oui c'est des crustacés
pour l'instant surtout du béton ou quoi
ouais je crois queas tu as le de béton
c'est une tradition ici c'est incroyable
il sont chiant faire sur le côté ou on
va déjà le décaler pour qu'il nous gène
moins et surtout pour essayer de
récupérer les quand même 1 2 3 ok il y
aut chose je pense que j'ai ah sur ton
derrière ouais c'est possible vas-y 1 2
des chosesant
il a plein de choses sin de
Ch tuas encore les autres objets ah oui
ça c'est une PPE à graisse encore ouis
ouis ok bon c'est bien ou
début avec son OS là il sait toujours
pas où le
mettre
mer
pas vu
ça con un peu là moi je pense qu'il faut
faire on détache mais non on jete la
corde et on repêche les mains c'est
dangereux
bah je pense que
oui alors là on a fait une bêtise on va
essayer de pas mourir
même pas vu le fil ah si si moi je l'IS
vu non je jette on a pas 36 solutions
hein hein ah il faut jeter bien entre
les deux c'est ça le problème non après
au pire on chape les mains et on tire de
l'autre côté mais
aantanteter et ouais c'était sûr
pe aller rater bah ouais ben prends son
a et en fait façon s
[Applaudissements]
ok ahis mais bon
c'est dangereux c'est quand même
dangereux j'aurais dit déjà pas avec des
gants mouillé
non je sais pas non pourra le faire avec
un bâton on met le bâton dans le truc de
l' et on tient que le bâton alors là
selon moi c'est quand Mme hyper
dangereux parce que je vais essayer de
vous le zoomer voyez leur de pêche qui
est planté dans le câble donc moy que le
câble soit nu juste à gauche qu'on
essaie de passer un bâton dans les MS là
et pour tirer seulement avec le
bâton
ok c'est bon on peut commencer à pêcher
ouais personne n'est mort ah un indice
ça ça vient d'une moto non c'est la une
moto non ouais mais qui va sur une moto
ah a la
plaque ah oui oh c'est une plaque noire
carrément
ouais dites-moi en commentaire ce que
vous en pensez mais pour moi c'est une
vieille Honda
je
pense
sympa la moto est peut-être aussi
dessous quentinou peut-être tu vas la
remonter toi parce que moi j'ai un peu
la flemme là c'est ça que je sens tire
sur le côté comme le P ouais allez bah
cherchons la
[Musique]
moto on va regarder mais j'ai encore des
truc
ouais alors qu'est-ce que c'est ça je
crois que ça vient d'une enceinte
sûrement j'ai peut-être quelque chose
enfin après le panneau
ou
là qu'est-ce que c'est c'est un morceau
de l'échelle
non
waouh on va aller sur le côté tu V
m'aider
Ouar faire des trous là arrête
d'enterrer ton partout
mangele ça bien
ouais j'aime bien le
poids toi tuas tu Paris sur une moto
ouais encore maintenant ou ouais ah oui
d'accord ça rigole pas là on est sur
quelque chose de massif alors moi
j'espère que c'est le reste de la moto
on va voir he c'est possible cool bon
par contre il va falloir tirer ça ça va
être moins cool tiens avec les r C'est
tout
là c'est très lourd on peut trer là
ouais
tu pense qu'on va y arriver je pense pas
on peut réessayer 1 2
[Musique]
3 donc là on a décidé d'utiliser le Tru
on aurait peut-être réussi en tirant à
de mais on n pas envie de se bousill le
dos c'est le début de la journée
ouis un bon point d'c prof ouais c'est
parfait
[Musique]
une grosse
moto pas si grosse mais a 2
3 ah ça tue he il y a pas deessence 1 2
3 ah tu le vois c'est pas ça pas d'êre
une moto
c'est
bizarre 1 2
3 W qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
machin je sais pas mais ça fait du bon
poid pour la ferraille oh oui ça je le
sais oh mais c'est un coffre
non un coffre fort dessous coffre fort
sur pied ouais c'est une première ça
voilà comme ça lui il nous embête pas
ok oh elle a enlevé le cach de la GoPro
oh non
ouais stop c'est bon c'est bon vous avez
le coffre fort ici bon malheureusement
je pense qu'à part des petite crevett il
y auras rien dedans sauf si on arrive à
soulever un peu ces plaques là et vous
avez la marque avec une plaque ah il y a
la plaque ouais il y a encore la plaque
du coffre début 20e c'est une dinguerie
je crois le poids qu'il fait hein ouais
ah en vrai ouaisid la p
attends on encore un beau bébé hein je
sais pas trop en quoi il est s'il y a du
béton mais je pense
alors c'est du fer
pur attends attends attends ah trop
tard bon vous l'avez vu la corde à laché
mais rasta nous a suggéré une nouvelle
idée
ce qu'on va faire maintenant c'est qu'on
va procéder en deux temps on va mettre
le treuil dans un premier temps pour le
soulever jusqu'à ce niveaau-là et une
fois que le coffre fort est remonté
jusqu'à là on va l'attacher de l'autre
côté et le finir avec le Peugeot
Expert ok bon c'est
[Musique]
bon finalement on fait l'inverse on lève
avec
plus comme ça au
fin ah c'est très
[Musique]
lourd bien
joué boulot é pas facile voilà on
combienhe cé
long vol encore une fois allez on défit
tout ça Contin on le met droit et on
continue en fait il aime tellement son
OS qu'il veut pas le manger il veut le
cacher deè peut-êre ça le fait ah j'ai
soulevé un truc là
ouais
ouais on dirait un maillot de
bain attends je l'ai
peut-être bah en fait c'est quand même
oh ouais c'est vrai c'est ça c'est un
joli poil à fioule alors ça on en a
pêché il y a très très longtemps ouais
ah bais il y a 3 ans
environ bien
joué là j'ai un truc cétait sous le pont
oh là là qu'est-ce que c'est encore
Hur oh il y a des bijoux
oui il y a pas qu' un peu de bijou c'est
un filtre c'est un filtre un peu
d'échappement non transparent ouais jeis
pas c'est regarde
ouis peutêtre il est bizarre hein jamais
vu un truc transparent comme ça ouais
c'est ch c'est étrange hein en
commentair non c'est pas ça qui
m'intéresse c'est plus ça quandme plus
ça c'était peut-être ce qu'il y avait
dans le coffre ça ouais ça c'est
possible wouh W W W W ça fait plaisir
bon c'est du fantasy mais tout qui Moné
tu crois testele ça c'est testele du de
là ça c'est des ah is il se casse ah
c'est des scoopyo on dirait là il y a
une bague regarde ouais là la bague
ouais ça c'est des scouidou quand tu qui
ont mal Vieli je crois ouais oh là là il
y a des bijoux là dessous on dirait un
peu du toque mais ils sont pas forcément
émentés he regarde ouais c'est pas c'est
pas tout émenté bon bien tu vas tester
ta bague non non elle pas aimenté non
ouais
ok bon il faut mettre tout ça dans un
coin là ouais tril est
bien je vais retirer vraiment tier
dessous alors ouais ouais ça c'est quoi
c'est une fleur ah oui ok bon ben sympa
aussi he même si c'est sûrement du toc
ça fait toujours plaisir et ça regarde
là ça il y a que le fermoire qui
estimenté tuas vu ah ouais peut-être un
petit truc enargent
ouais la couleur c'est possible euh je
vais mettre de côté ah ça vient pas du
poil à Fule et si ah ouais mais oui
c'est làdedans qui a la
combustion oh attends attends est-ce
qu'elle est pleine ah non
ouais ah dommage ou là c'est beau mais
ouais
perdu des moules c'est des moules ça un
morceau de voiture mais ouais je pense
mais très très ancien vous l'avez vu il
y avait un big coffre fort ici il reste
deux trois trucs dans la vase mais sinon
globalement c'est très propre on va
passer à l'autre côté du pont ah non moi
je voulais d'abord qu' ti des côtés ah
non moi je veux commencer là d'abord tu
veux on se sépare non oh non c'est quoi
ça encore il a plein de pics oh là là
c'est des morceaux de chaînne ou je sais
pas quoi alors là je suis sur une piste
mais j'ai peur que ce soit un bout de
gouttière parce que regardez il y en a
une qui descend ici dans l'eau elle est
là-bas de l'autre côté du pont donc il
manque un bout et c'est lourd ouais oui
oui oui bien vu ça accroche bienés
thérapeute m'a dit d'arrêter de faire ce
genre de bêtises le dos droit le dos
droit là tu peux clairement pas le dos
droit
dos droit do droit attention
posture bon au moins te gênera plus ouis
je sais pas TR où la mettre dans
l'utilitaire dans l'utilitaire qu'on pr
la coup ouis non c'est bon on va la
laisser s'il veulent la réparer
maintenant tu crois
non pêcher c'est pêché tout ce qui est
dans l'eau appartient à
l'État B ça va
oh non c'est un
panneau un panneau sans le Panau a pas
de panneau il y a que le piquet du
panneau alors Quentin s'est posté en
face maintenant on va avancer vers la
droite là-bas pas grand chose mais on va
peut-être tenter une nouvelle technique
qu'on aime bien faire de temps en temps
c'està dire accrocher nos éains ensemble
et ratisser en tirant droite gauche
droite
[Applaudissements]
gauche ah mais est-ce que no cordes sont
assez
longues maintenant on va essayer de
regarder ce qu'il y a sur les aimants
mais on a pas assez de cordes donc pour
ça je vais essayer d'en rajouter un peu
vas-y tu peux y
aller je vais devoir tendre le bras
après ça sort de
l'eau il y a Caden de
cadenas Caden cassé un autre Caden cassé
un piquet en fer vas-y retire un peu on
se met là là vas-y
oui
il y a quelques
trucs je sais pas trop ce que c'est
ça je sais pas si vous savez en
commentaire pour ceux qui se demandent
nos aims viennent du site de maison de
la détection donc nous on utilise
celui-ci ça c'est le barbarien 1600 kg
donc il a une force de 1600 kg réparti
sur 360° et je peux vous
dire que c'est du lourd bah bien sur là
ça va lâcher mais en même temps il pèse
200 kg le coffre et donc voilà si vous
souhaitez vous équiper vous avez
différentes gammes et vous avez le code
promo pêcheur de trésor qui offre 5 %
sur toute la boutique y compris sur les
détecteurs regardez rasta comme il est
adorable et comme il a validé cet
instant
promotion fais pas écraser
dessous bien
joué voilà monstre
debout il est quand même ass grand pas
compte du poid mais c'est un truc de ouf
on sait pas s'il a du béton
dedans malgré le vent il bouga
pas a changé de spot un petit peu décalé
ici on est proche de la cité on trouvé
plein de choses les vidéos s'affich un
peu partout je rigole on pe pas faire
vidé
description
ok
encore deè OK et moi wou un morceau
d'enceinte
ou classique prot Toxide d'azotex
d'azote c'est quand même rempli ici ah
bah oui pour toxite
aussi ça je sais plus ce que c'est ça
mais j'ai déjà
vu btiste j'ai besoin de toi
il y a du lourd là moto peut-être mais
ça va venir je pense à deux j'espère
parce que pour trouyer ici c'est pas
facile ah oui ça vient ça vient et le
poid tu as vu ouais c'est
correct
oh c'est bien ah oui
d'accord m je sais just ça me revenait
pas ah oui c'est c'est
c'est cool pas très VI
cel toute petite voiture ça ah ou c'est
c'est une petite voiture c'est
ou je sais pas en commenta siz
ID mais il est pas vie des C ouais c'est
vrai c'est V ça c'est to contre ah
nickel c'estcile à
transporter ré
attention
OK
oh non c est plus grosse que les
autres
ok mais c'est quoi ça c'est un
meuble cuivre de
cuiv non ça va
h bon pour petite pince à linge ah ouais
un crochet ou
ouais ouais c'est sympa ça et ben ça
s'en fait des petits ballons ici hein ah
vraiment c'est un co tu as que du proto
et encore des petites taquettes là comme
tout à l'heure
et un bijou viens voir et franchement il
est pas mal attends je remonte
d'abord
ah il est
cassé
non dans mes
MS c'était un
collier avec un sacré gros pendentif
ouais bon il tombe en miette un peu mais
ouais pas mal
ouais sympa ouais franchement bravo et
en plus ça ça accroché sur un endroit où
il y avait pas mal de choses on aurait
dit ouais ouais peut-être que ça ça
vient d'un coffre ou d'un sac ou quoi on
les mettre là pour l'instant c'était
dans le coin des
bijoux ben c'est pas des bijoux
ouis encore une
enceinte il y a que des aimants en fait
dans ce
canal regarde je sais pas pourquoi il y
en autant qui pêch avec j'ai pêché ah
j'ai pas
pêché ah si j'ai
pêché on les compte même
plus encore un alternateur j'ai
l'impression ouais heureusement on
connait quelqu'un qui nous les reprend
maintenant les alternateurs ou les
protoxyes allez de ha le couteau oh
c'est le bijou mais ça regarde ah j'ai
pas vu ça
ouais moi j'ai vu le couteau la gueule
avec la fameuse abeille c'est un
vrai il y a plus de bois par contre et
ouais la petite bague là avec le
brillant ouis ben en fait c'est un très
beau lancé ça c'est
quoiintérie le couteau tu vois très bien
c'est vra bon il est un peu tordu mais
ça reste la très bonne qualité
440 ah oui
Okou trs biench je vois le truc jeis
domage
Braz c'est
bon
[Musique]
allez
oh un sac
non c'est
quoi si c'est un
sac ah des
bombes bombe de
tag
neutralisanteur
ok une
brosse d'accord
ok étonnant et avec ça une
pince et làdedans dans cette pochette
c'est
vide
ok
étonnant étonnant de
trouvaille je crois que j'ai un moulinet
ouais
que regarde ce moulinet il tourne encore
j'ai le pot de tout à l'heure ah le
retour du pot d'échappement maudit à la
pente ça va moins
rigoler tu veux pas qu'on le fasse à
deux bon ben voilà c'est la fin de la
journée on est fatigué encore le soleil
mais se coucher on bien travaill max
coffreéchappement protoxide et surtout
quelques bijou mais je pense que c'est
du to mais on va regarder quand pas t
pas tous même le couteau quoi une fois
une FO restauré ça va un petit bet voilà
nous on dit à la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle vidéo de pêche
àment c'est bien c'est bien un beau
chien
allez on va regarder ce qu'on a ensemble
ok
allez on va voir ça b
b il s'en fiche il s'en fiche
OK